[Music]
it is not uncommon for popular authors
to inspire real devotion among their
fans but brandon sanderson may be taking
that to a whole new level he was already
the best-selling writer of fantasy and
science fiction novels proudly displayed
by these loyal readers but he recently
broke new ground with the news that he
broke to fans and the way they broke the
internet in return
over the last two years i've acted with
extreme irresponsibility on social media
author brandon sanderson's a bit of a
tease i kind of pretended i might be
retiring
yes no you didn't i did i did but
instead of a swan song i accidentally
wrote an extra novel in secret i might
have gone a little overboard and in an
ultimate plot twist brandon stress wrote
five new books trending on facebook
trending on twitter trending on youtube
thanks to that viral kickstarter
campaign he plans to publish and sell
directly to his fans he's already raised
more than 30 million dollars
and counting kickstarter is working
basically like a really fancy pre-order
for us
so instead of printing five or ten
thousand we're going to be printing 200
000 books i mean are you trying to stir
up the publishing world
no well
a little bit i am a little bit i mean
are you literally like
i'm trying to start a little someone i
don't want to you know what i like
amazon too it's really convenient but
they control 85 percent of the book
market
and back about a decade ago they had
contract disputes
with my publisher amazon turned off the
ability to buy my books for a month for
a month
my income vanished 85 of it just gone
and i've never forgotten that sanderson
credits that long memory and
entrepreneurial spirit to his mom
barbara an accountant who also inspired
his determination
i wrote 13 novels before i sold one
so what happened is 13 13. i got a job
working at a hotel
at the graveyard shift 10 p.m till 7 a.m
and i
would write books on the computer at the
front desk elantris published in 2005
was his first he now has 51 books under
his belt with 23 million copies sold i
am signing eight thousand copies of
psytonic success that spawned his
company dragon steel entertainment
headquartered outside of salt lake city
what we've got here is
my book covers in china and his eclectic
lifestyle this is like an old time
screening room yes case in point he
built his very own underground man cave
like i said this is my big splurge
complete with a life-sized movie theater
you dug
but this uber success story shares his
wisdom consistency is way more important
every thursday night you'll find him
teaching creative writing at his alma
mater brigham young university try to
avoid making up words he even posts his
classes for free online we are living in
probably the best time to be a writer
that's ever existed because
with the advent of ebooks you don't have
to sell a physical product which is the
real hard thing if you want to
self-publish but it's way more
democratized now and so
this is if you're thinking of being a
writer this is the best time and the
popularity of streaming has delivered an
appetite to segway those supernatural
books to the screen what are those
his harmony is coming
take the wheel of time
amazon spent a reported 80 million
dollars on the show based on a book
series as sanderson finished after the
death of author robert jordan he is now
a producer on the show we're in kind of
a renaissance right now of fantasy and
science fiction a lot of cool things we
have things like the witcher we have our
cane yes love the witch oh man
fantasy is a really broad umbrella of
storytelling it's anything that is
impossible that we pretend is possible
for a little while so for instance
hamlet with ghosts is fantasy we have
romance as powerful as any romantic
fiction out there we have outlander you
go back in time
you're a fantasy science fiction story
anything you can write in any other
genre you can put in fantasy plus you
can have dragons sanderson plans to
bring his own magic to life entertaining
offers for tv and film rights for his
books most of which are set in an
interconnected universe called the
cosmere i got really lucky in that right
around the time i released i finally
sold a book in 2003 and it came out in
2005.
two years later a big revolution in
entertainment happened
yes
uh so we're talking marvel we're talking
marvel the marvel cinematic universe
happened and
because of that people are like oh we
love interconnected characters in worlds
and meanwhile i had been doing this for
a few years and people just latched on
to it well what is the big dream the big
dream the big dream is to um to be stan
lee
do you know stan lee
who doesn't know stanley i would love to
be stan lee the person whose stories
have changed millions of lives that are
beloved they've been retold time and
time and time again that bring so much
joy and fond memories to people's lives
that's who i would like to be whether i
can do it or not is another question but
that's my aspiration i believe he's on
his way but this is the best part of the
story so he first started writing that
that those books in secret
and the first novel was actually just
for his wife
she read it really loved it she said
honey you gotta share that's cheers and
he keeps sharing i love that